Today I've got two fantastic news beans
in the news pod it's co-host of CBS Mornings,
The lovely Nate Burleson.
(applause)
How you doing, what's up?
I am freaking out to be next to you.
I'll get into that in a minute.
And obviously the cohost of Drew's News,
right here every day, my anchor Ross Mathews.
Hi, hi.
(applause)
Can we just say how excited we are that you are here today.
I am a huge Seahawks fan.
Go on! That's what I'm talking about.
I know.
Ross you love football!
Every Sunday.
you want to hang out?
You want to go football?
Yeah lets do it.
You wanna get in a fantasy league together?
Uh OK yeah
I'm a little worried
my fantasy league might be different than yours though.
OK. Well what fantasy are we talking about?
Yeah exactly Nate, that's where I was going.
I think when it comes to football,
your fantasies, I mean, they might align actually.
Honestly if we could go out
and just toss a football around
on like 57th street. Would you ever do that with me?
Lets do that. 100%
Okay. Stay tuned.
So now we have a date,
I gotta come back.
We're good with that?
Okay.
I'm just so glad you're here in the first place,
because I bragged to my kids about this.
You would think, I was like girls. (sniffs)
(laughter)
I am gonna get to co-anchor CBS Morning News.
And they were like, (sighs),
(laughter)
and I am there,
and I am watching you Nate.
And I'm literally like,
this is the biggest star
This is a star, star star star.
And I was talking to Shauna, the producer,
and I was like,
I mean I can't take my eyes off him.
He has just got it.
He is a star.
And obviously she knew something
that she couldn't tell me at the time.
But then it was announced
that you are the co host permanently.
Yes!
(applause)
And CBS Mornings is just on fire.
And I'm just so glad that you're
a huge part of that,
because you really are.
You can't take your eyes off of you Nate.
You're so good.
I want to stay here. I like this
Yeah you should.
But no no, I appreciate that.
And I'm just part of the team,
and it's not just Gail, Tony and I,
we have a long list of men and women,
that have come before us
and that are working with us now.
And sometimes the world can seem a bit chaotic,
and sometimes the news can pull you down a little bit.
But what we do is we give you the news,
and we give you it in a way that you are equipped
to take on the world.
But then also we will uplift you.
We will make you smile,
and give you something that you can feel like you can
take on the rest of your day with.
That's what we do on CBS mornings.
We could use A little bit of that.
Thank you for that
(applause)
Thank you, to CBS Mornings.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Well, shall we get into some news?
Yes!
Oh let's do it.
Lets get into some news
All right! Okay.
This one's a fun one.
And I think like made and tailored for you, Nate.
It's scary movie season. That's right.
It's Halloween.
Oooooh
(laughter)
That is the vision
of a middle aged white woman cracking herself up.
(laughter)
and we've got big questions for horror fans.
Can an indie horror movie be just as scary
as one with a huge budget?
The New York post reports that a company called,
Finance Buzz is gonna test this.
They're hiring a horror heart rate analyst
to watch 13 scary movies across all budgets,
while wearing heart rate monitors.
I know I love this.
The movies range from a Paranormal Activity
which costs 15,000 to make
That's a good one.
to A Quiet Place two which cost 60 million.
All right, Nate.
Yes?
Thoughts?
I love horror movies.
Oh god.
I'm all in. I'm all in.
(applause)
You guys love horror movies?
You feel me?
Got a couple snaps up there. Yeah!
See I feel like fear is something we don't tap into enough.
You know, I love a good jump out scare,
when you're walking down the hallway.
I love a good haunted house.
No, you know who you don't want
to be sitting in front of in a horror movie?
Ross Matthews. Okay.
Really?
Because it's not for me.
I'd rather watch Bridges Of Madison county 100 times,
than one horror movie.
Give me Steel Magnolias.
You think the movie's scary?
Wait till you hear me shriek behind you.
Not good.
No, listen.
There's nothing like watching a movie so scary,
that you gotta watch cartoons before you go to bed.
I'm talking about a movie so scary,
that when you take out the trash at night,
you run full speed back to the house,
'cause you know the boogieman's coming.
Yes!
All right. We have you here. You look amazing.
So we have to talk about a fashion comeback.
All right?
Now, Barrymore, you are at the cutting edge of this one.
Take a look.
The New York times reports that the sweater vest,
oh, she back
and this time she is sexy.
Check this out.
Shawn Mendes, Harry styles, Dwayne Johnson,
all rocking a sexy vest.
Now Drew, I actually looked at the show,
and I noticed you have on occasion,
worn a sweater vest on this show.
(applause)
And I think the audience just voted you vest dressed.
Oh OK.
I'm actually wearing one today too.
(applause)
But for women wearing vests,
my chest can look like two egg McMuffins in a vest,
so I gotta be careful.
(laughter)
You gotta choose that vest really wisely.
It's true though
Now, listen, I'm not exactly what you would call,
a boob man so I don't get it.
But egg McMuffin Drew?
Just like weird. They're just,
it can give you an odd shape as a woman.
Listen, egg McMuffins are very popular, so
And delicious!
I'm just throwing that out there.
(applause)
I don't even know how Nate,
you're gonna transition to the next story.
I love a good sweater vest.
I rock sweater vest.
Look at that. That's me.
(applause)
At work.
Yes!
You see?
You know you're such a fashionable man.
You have a whole like suit situation,
and shoes and.
Yeah.
Well, I got my legs out right now.
Oh hey!
(applause)
What? Now.
Sorry. I didn't mean to show my egg McMuffins.
put that away.
(laughter)
I was just thinking,
that's like medieval times,
like turkey like situation.
Oh my god.
You know, a little seriousness up top,
party on the bottom.
I love it.
What was the catalyst for fashion for you?
Cause you have a line of suits
Yeah.
you have many pairs of shoes you collect.
No doubt
Where did that sort of impetus get born?
I've always felt like what we put
on our exterior stays says a lot about who we are,
and how we feel about ourselves.
And I wanted to create a clothing line that was affordable,
that was fresh and fly, that a young man,
who didn't have a ton of money in his pocket
could buy so he can look good when he's doing his thing.
Oh Nate!
Come on.
(applause)
Oh my god. I love you.
I know. Obsessed Drew.
you guys gonna make me cry up in here.
It's happened before